como te imaginas un átomo así o así o
tal vez como uno de estos si entiendes
lo suficiente acerca de los átomos para
visualizar cualquiera de esas cosas
entonces sabes más sobre la teoría
atómica que los científicos de hace sólo
100 años y mucho más de lo que pensaban
que sabían hace 2500 años
fue entonces cuando el filósofo griego
leucipo y su alumno demócrito tuvieron
la idea de que la materia está compuesta
de pequeñas partículas nadie sabe cómo
desarrollaron este concepto pero no
pensaron que las partículas fueron
particularmente especiales solo pensaron
que si cortas algo por la mitad
suficientes veces en algún momento
llegarás a una partícula que ya no se
puede cortar le dieron a estas
partículas el nombre de átomos
incontable o indivisible lo que
significa que no se puede cortar o que
no se puede dividir entonces básicamente
pensaron que el hierro estaba hecho de
partículas de hierro la arcilla estaba
hecha de partículas de arcilla y el
queso estaba hecho de partículas de
queso y atribuyeron propiedades de cada
sustancia a las formas del átomo
entonces pensaron que los átomos de
hierro eran duros y unidos con ganchos
los átomos de arcilla eran más blandos y
estaban unidos por articulaciones
esféricas que los
inflexibles y los átomos de queso eran
blandos y deliciosos y esto tiene
sentido si no tienes acceso a
microscopios electrónicos o tubos de
rayos catódicos o al trabajo de
generaciones de científicos anteriores
porque el hecho es que la teoría atómica
tal como la conocemos hoy es el producto
de cientos sino miles de ideas
diferentes algunos modelos como el de
leucipo eran sólo conjeturas ciegas con
el paso del tiempo muchos otros fueron
el resultado de una experimentación
rigurosa pero como ha sido el caso en
toda la ciencia cada científico se basó
en lo que se había aprendido antes hemos
estado hablando mucho sobre los detalles
finos de la química en las últimas
semanas y seguiremos haciéndolo a medida
que avancemos a la química nuclear y
luego a los conceptos básicos de la
química orgánica pero antes de hacerlo
quería reservar algo de tiempo para
explicar cómo sabemos lo que hoy sabemos
sobre el átomo y cómo sabemos que aún no
hemos terminado de descubrirlo
[Música]
ahora puedes pensar que una vez que al
éxito y demócrito se les ocurrió la idea
general de los átomos sería bastante
fácil para otra persona tomar esa
pequeña bola indivisible y correr con
ella pero te equivocarás los siguientes
desarrollos importantes en la teoría
atómica no llegarían en los siguientes
casi 2300 años ya te he contado por
ejemplo sobre el químico francés antoine
la bo cierto que propuso la ley de la
conservación de la masa que establece
que incluso si la materia cambia de
forma su masa se mantiene igual y debes
recordar al profesor de inglés john
dalton quien determinó que los elementos
existen como paquetes discretos de
materia gracias a estas y otras grandes
mentes del siglo 19 se pudo comprender
mejor el comportamiento general de los
átomos la siguiente pregunta lógica fue
por qué por qué se comportan como lo
hacen esto condujo a la investigación de
la estructura atómica en la década de
1870 los científicos comenzaron a
investigar de qué estaban hechas las
cosas utilizando tubos de descarga
básicamente todos llenos de gas con
electrodos en cada extremo que emiten
luz cuando una corriente eléctrica los
atraviesa esencialmente es una luz de
neón debido a que esta luz fue producida
originalmente por un electrodo negativo
o un cato
se llamó rayo catódico y tenía una carga
negativa pero en 1886 el físico alemán
eugen goldstein descubrió que los tubos
también emitían luz desde el electrodo
positivo básicamente un rayo que se
dirigía en la dirección opuesta lo que
significaba que también debía haber una
carga positiva en la materia goldstein
no entendió completamente lo que había
descubierto aquí me refiero a que los
científicos todavía no habían
descubierto que era responsable de la
carga negativa en los rayos luego el
físico inglés jj thompson llevó la
investigación del tubo de descarga más
allá al medir cuánto calor generaban los
rayos catódicos cuando podían ser
doblados por imanes y otras cosas pudo
estimar la masa de los rayos y la masa
era aproximadamente mil veces más ligera
que el hidrógeno la parte de materia más
pequeña conocida en ese momento llegó a
la conclusión de que los rayos catódicos
no eran rayos ni ondas en absoluto sino
que en realidad eran partículas muy
pequeñas muy ligeras y cargadas
negativamente
los llamo corpúsculos nosotros los
llamamos electrones entonces aunque no
entendíamos qué forma tenían sabíamos
que eran componentes negativos y
positivos de la materia la siguiente
pregunta fue cómo se organizan dentro
del átomo
thompson sabía que el átomo en general
tenía una carga neutra por lo que
imagino que los electrones cargados
negativamente deben distribuirse
aleatoriamente en una matriz cargada
positivamente y el muy inglés thompson
visualizo este modelo como un postre
inglés familiar pudin de ciruela la
matriz positiva es el budín y los
electrones son los trozos de fruta
flotando al azar dentro de ella incluso
hoy el modelo del átomo de thompson
continua llamándose el modelo de budín
de ciruela y aunque el movimiento de un
solo electrón es aleatorio su
distribución en general no lo es el
siguiente gran paso fue dado por el
neocelandés ernest rutherford en 1909
diseñó un experimento utilizando una
lámina extremadamente delgada de papel
de oro y una pantalla recubierta con
sulfuro de zinc bombardeó la lámina con
partículas alfa que realmente no sabía
que eran sólo que eran producidas por la
descomposición del radio estaban
cargadas positivamente y eran muy muy
pequeñas se esperaba que pasaran a
través de la lámina sin desviarse y
muchas de ellas lo hicieron pero resultó
que algunas de las partículas se
desviaron en ángulos grandes y a veces
casi hacia atrás la única explicación
para esto fue que toda la carga
y va en un átomo la carga que repele una
partícula alfa debe concentrarse en un
área muy pequeña un área que llamo el
núcleo debido a que la mayoría de las
partículas alfa pasaron a través de los
átomos sin inmutarse en bruto el foro
concluyó que la mayor parte del átomo es
un espacio vacío y estaba en lo correcto
rutherford más tarde descubriría que si
bombardeaba nitrógeno con partículas
alfa creaba un montón de iones de
hidrógeno
ahora supuso correctamente que estos
pequeños iones cargados positivamente
eran en sí mismos partículas
fundamentales protones ahora nos
acercamos a la realidad estos químicos
tenían una idea bastante buena de la
estructura del átomo sólo necesitaban
averiguar qué estaban haciendo
exactamente los electrones aquí entra
niels bohr en 1911 el mismo año en que
se publicaron los resultados del
experimento de la lámina de oro de
rutherford ball viajó a inglaterra para
estudiar con rutherford y como físico
también estaba interesado en los modelos
matemáticos establecidos por los físicos
alemanes max planck y albert eisntein
para explicar el comportamiento de la
energía electromagnética con el tiempo
board se dio cuenta de que estos
principios matemáticos podían aplicarse
al modelo atómico de rutherford su
análisis
los cálculos del experimento de la
lámina de oro basados en la proporción
de partículas alfa que atravesó
directamente las que se desviaron
ligeramente y las que rebotaron casi
completamente hacia atrás le permitió
predecir las posiciones más probables de
electrones dentro del átomo el modelo
resultante de board a veces llamado
modelo planetario todavía es familiar
para la mayoría de las personas
probablemente incluyéndote a ti
representa los electrones en órbitas
alrededor de un pequeño núcleo central
cada órbita puede tener un número
específico de electrones que se
correlacionan con los niveles de energía
y los orbitales en el modelo moderno del
átomo y aunque es definitivamente
erróneo el modelo de vor estaba muy
cerca de la realidad en algunos aspectos
importantes pero como todos los que he
mencionado en los últimos minutos x
tenía muchísima razón y al mismo tiempo
estaba muy equivocado el problema eran
esos molestos electrones fue el físico
teórico alemán werner heisenberg quien
hizo que todos entendieran juan grande y
alucinante era este problema de los
electrones pero también fue él quien ato
todo el desastre en un pequeño paquete
ordenado usando sus perversas
habilidades matemáticas heisenberg
descubrió que es imposible saber con
certeza el momento de un electro
o cualquier partícula subatómica y su
posición exacta y cuanto más sepas sobre
una de esas dos variables más difícil
será medir la otra y si no puedes medir
la posición o el momento de un electrón
obviamente no puedes decir con certeza
que los electrones en un átomo están
perfectamente alineados en órbitas
circulares por lo que el y una nueva ola
de físicos y químicos propusieron una
nueva teoría una teoría cuántica que
propone que los electrones no eran
partículas u ondas sino que tenían
propiedades de ambos y de ninguno con
este pensamiento la disposición de los
electrones alrededor de un núcleo solo
podría describirse en términos de
probabilidad en otras palabras hay
ciertas regiones donde es mucho más
probable encontrar un electrón llamamos
a estas regiones orbitales ya sabes los
mismos orbitales de los que tú y yo
hemos estado hablando los que tienen los
nombres esp dee y efe y que forman
enlaces sigma y pi estas son las cosas
que predice la teoría de heisenberg y
esa es la comprensión moderna de los
átomos debido a que se basa en la
probabilidad los átomos de estilo
cuántico a menudo se dibujan como nubes
con una intensidad de color que no
representa electrones individuales sino
la probabilidad de encontrar
un electrón en cualquier posición en
particular por esta razón el modelo
cuántico a menudo se llama el modelo de
nube del átomo y ahora ya lo sabes todas
las personas que he mencionado y muchas
otras se unieron con el tiempo para
construir esta corriente y podría
decirse que es una comprensión bastante
elegante de la teoría atómica ahora
después de 2500 años a pesar de que no
podemos verlos podemos saber cómo son y
cómo funcionan porque una larga sucesión
de científicos contribuyó con un poco de
toda la fantástica imagen pero también
es importante reconocer que puede que
aún no estemos del todo bien los
contemporáneos de thompson estaban
seguros de que el modelo de budín de
ciruelas era correcto los científicos de
la época de borg creían plenamente que
el modelo planetario tenía razón y hoy
estamos extremadamente seguros de que el
modelo cuántico es correcto pero puede
que no sea del todo correcto y ahí es
donde entras tú
la única forma en que podemos estar
seguros es seguir haciendo preguntas y
realizando experimentos